we're in a field on the outskirts of
Berlin it's time for the radish harvest
everything picked here is sold and eaten
that might sound obvious but it's not
half the food produced in Germany ends
up in the trash that's 750 truck loads a
day 11 million tons per year many
farmers discard unwanted produce at the
picking stage spoiled vegetables are not
allowed to be sold and retailers don't
want anything that doesn't look exactly
the way the customers want it does isn't
true Bashar misfit garage farmer
Christian Hyman says such vegetables are
labeled misfits he shows us a kohlrabi
that has split it normally would never
be sent to market because of its
appearance but farmer Hyman will
definitely make sure it's appreciated it
and he kissed it so it goes straight
into our crate because we're on a
mission to save food
we want to find out how to stop so much
food from ending up in the trash and
meet some people who are already doing
it people like farmer Christian Hyman
who runs a project called spies a goat
or food well every week he packs crates
of fruit and vegetables for his
customers including of course the
misfits the farmer and his workers call
it solidarity agriculture and they began
this year with three hectares of land
hymen has a group of ready customers who
finance scenes and farming costs for
produce such as this lettuce some
alpinum convince an end Haemon says that
in conventional farming the size of a
potato is decided before it has even
grown that way consumers have no choice
about whether the carrots are curved or
a radish has split his philosophy is
that consumers should be able to have a
say in what they eat and they can choose
locally grown fresh vegetables from him
inside and start my flesh is committed
to become this lettuce may be locally
grown and fresh but it's too small for a
supermarket hymens customers don't mind
though and they're prepared to pay 13
euros for their weekly crate of produce
it might not be cheaper than the
aesthetically perfect veg on sale in the
supermarket's but it is healthy and it
tastes just as good
the next stage is all about getting the
food to the customers as freshly as
possible my unball mr. Hyman says he
adapts his harvest to the number of
customers so he only grows as much as he
needs in the summertime when he often
ends up with more than necessary the
access is immediately used in some way
so if he has too many zucchinis he'll
make zucchini chutney for example so we
need chatni hora window and don't but
the bulk of hymens crops go straight to
his customers we visited one of them in
an indoor market in the Berlin district
of coins Berg chef lohan team runs a
canteen there with a focus on regional
produce and sustainable methods he has
no problem with worm damaged vegetables
for example he shows us a radish that
would never normally be used but he
points out that most of it is still all
right once the bad bits have been cut
away he says no one will know the
difference apart from the fact that less
food is being wasted little fish minute
run the cooking and the philosophy
behind it have caught on in a city where
many people are very conscious of what
they eat misfit radishes are always
welcome here
but in an affluent country like Germany
that's the exception rather than the
rule it's well-known that supermarkets
throw away a lot of perfectly edible
food but how much we contacted several
major chains but all refuse to comment
still some people are reacting to the
waist they're known as dumpster divers
we decided to meet one and we were
warmly greeted as fellow food savers
benjamin schmidt is a 21 year old
student he agreed to take us on a dive
through some dumpsters in search of
edible waste Evan or just fin de neve
appreciates that you've ever buys me off
on me when I'm if I had no miles gave me
I'd initial screen insists he's not
doing it to save money he wants to keep
his ecological footprint as small as
possible while drawing attention to the
huge quantities of edible food that end
up in supermarket dumpsters my pun pun
done after closing time we head into the
backyard of a small supermarket first
stop the fruit and vegetable bins done
Junior many months principle is simple
so check everything and put the good
stuff into a crate he immediately finds
some good veg we're amazed it's like a
culinary treasure hunt and the darkness
adds to the thrill in fact what we're
doing is theft this food is still the
property of the supermarket benjamine
will even take slightly damaged goods
such as a split tomato if it looks like
it's still fresh we try to get as much
as possible without attracting attention
but then we are suddenly approached my
lord esketh some family like passerby
has come to express her support for what
we're doing she says she also gets angry
about how much food is thrown away here
so casually yeah so we're not the only
ones who are concerned about food waste
it's dumpster diving becoming socially
acceptable at the moment it's restricted
to political activists and the poor yeah
by Stefan Matteau in besant eyes open
yum yum koi we continue to pull out one
piece of perfect veg after another this
cauliflower doesn't have a single mark
on it absolute fish mini model optician
but it's not all plain sailing the first
bins might have been okay but others are
less appetizing a lot of the things we
are now finding have past their sell-by
dates there's pre cooked food meat &
pâtés it's illegal to sell these
products once they've expired we don't
really want to take any of this home
with us but then again there's still
plenty of good food here such as some
tasty-looking bananas zindagi knife the
bucket from what are our tool by the
time we're done we found some rich
pickings and it's not just fruit and veg
we've got cartons of yogurt and curd
cheese that are due to expire soon but
Benjamin explains that they can keep for
another couple of weeks or months after
the printed used by date in this type of
Christ items an officer would Kenisha we
take a few items for ourselves and leave
the rest for Benny mean he'll take his
share and post the rest on an internet
site called food sharing
it's karma the system allows people with
more food than they need to pass it on
for free we find a tasty sounding food
basket in Berlin and set up a handover
with the user Hoff ilf a few hours later
we need up with 29 year old half al
phila a long time food saver he tells us
he can feed his family for free using
the food sharing system in fact he says
he has too much at the moment so he's
giving it away before it goes bad it
sounds good to us two-thirds of the food
thrown away in Germany comes from
private households raphael takes us to
see a new project that the food sharers
have started with local organic
supermarkets many shoppers here are
quite picky about appearances and tend
to reject produce that is slightly
bruised or spotty but instead of
throwing away the rejects the
supermarket saves them up for the food
sharers that saves money on garbage
collection and is good PR to NHS also to
this shop assistant says it feels good
to pass on rejects knowing that someone
will be pleased about it and maybe make
a Mongol nasi or a nice salad that's who
on the physis college in Utah off and it
doesn't end up in the trash but with
Raphael and other food savers dunk then
then with my one sends fresh towel now
Raphael and his friends come here
several times a week and they often
collect more than they can distribute
I mean if this Alice by future he says
that if he posted everything on food
sharing then he would be spending four
or five hours a day handing it all out
few people have time for that lousy
answer hydrosol kushina Savannah
Callaham sophia tolli so the crates are
often simply handed over to those in
real need or to family and friends it's
a good way of getting good food to
people who can't go shopping themselves
for whatever reason but in the end
Raphael and his friends aren't
necessarily doing this for social
reasons they want to draw attention to
the culture of waste and to set an
example with their actions labels with
the first vandalism problema points out
that food waste is a problem that
affects us all and not just supermarkets
farms and restaurants so we should all
question our own behavior think the
sistema Virginia he says food waste is a
mainstream issue and everyone should
pull together to bring it down from its
current fifty percent level from from
st. James Parish Magnolia no meant no
harm survivors gate so they don't see so
far some 20,000 people have registered
with the food sharing site alone and we
can imagine joining them because we
found out how to save food too
we've harvested misfit vegetables in a
field pulled some tasty tidbits out of a
dumpster and saved other food from going
bad via food sharing mission
accomplished not only did we rescue all
that food from the trash but we also
saved a good 20 euros and have enough
food for several proper meals there's a
big feelgood factor in this but it's
still pretty shocking with all this good
food really being thrown away while we
can't see ourselves as regular dumpster
divers we are determined to throw away
as little as possible in the future so
now it's time to put this food where it
really belongs in our stocks